- So I hear that you love like diners
and like drive-ins, like dive bars,
like, is this true?
- Okay, so what's true
is that I love the show,
Diners, Drive-ins and Dives.
- Oh.
- The Guy Fieri show.
- Wait, so I love drive-ins.
- Yeah, yeah.
- and I love dive bars.
I think they're the,
sometimes it's like the best,
not for you, but it's the best food.
- It's the best food,
exactly.
- Yeah,
- So I love that show because
I just am obsessed with
Guy Fieri
- Yeah.
- and I'm obsessed with
the show and yeah,
- Yeah.
- let's give it up for
Guy Fieri for one second.
(audience applauding)
But I love it because
we love to like road trip and like
- Yeah.
- my husband's on tour
right now so we're in a lot
of different new places.
- A constant road trip.
But do you, see, you're
probably lucky though
because do you get to
'cause people think like
we go on tour, right.
- Right.
- But you're usually seeing
the hotel room and the airport.
- Yeah.
- You know, you don't really
get to, do you venture out,
do you get to do that?
- It depends on how
much time we're spending
- Yeah.
- in that one place.
It is actually usually really in and out,
but what I do is I go on
the diners, drive-ins and
ooh that's a tongue twister.
- Yeah, that's a tough one,
yeah.
- Dines, Drive-ins and Dives
website and I look at if there's anything
in the city that we're in
and I order takeout from the place.
- This is my vibe, yeah.
- So I can try it.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Yeah.